hallo meine damen und herren herzlich
willkommen hier heute zu diesem heutigen
video was heute aufgeladen er bereitete
lesen können wir treffen heute den
schleppen besten ford mitspieler
aufwachen nicht um ein produktionsteam
und wir haben dafür natürlich keine
kosten gescheut und besucher den besten
spieler
[Applaus]
[Musik]
so meine damen und herren sind jetzt nun
hier angekommen in den gleichen räumen
des geschlechtes besten spieler luca
schönen tag lacht die ehre ist ganz
meinerseits luca in ganz kurz ich glaube
für unsere zuschauer ist sehr
interessant für den neuen coach
vorstellen würde erstmal danke schön
dass ich ja alle eingeschaltet haben
dass hier tatsächlich eine reportage
über mich gedreht wird was natürlich
auch gerechtfertigt ist wenn mein
leistungen mein name ist luca ich bin
der so genannte beste fortnight spieler
okay das ist ja höchst interessant das
kann ja eigentlich jeder fordert ich
wieder von sich behaupten können sie
dies denn mit statistiken belegen ja
aber selbstverständlich
es gibt natürlich bei vorn da die
auktionen dass man sich seine
statistiken angucken kann die kann ich
euch hier auch einfach mal ganz einfach
einblenden
so sieht das bei mir nämlich aus wir
sehen schon eine unzählige anzahl an
siegen waren heute würde ich sagen meine
lieben zuschauer euch interessiert ja
nicht so krass dieses interview mit dem
hello kam mit dem ständig beste form ein
spieler sondern wir wollen natürlich
auch mal sehen wie sich der luca land
wirklich in dem spiel so schlägt lukas
würde ich dann mache ich dann ja jetzt
mal einfach vor ort in battle royale mit
luca also alle unter euch die ford nicht
so richtig kennen das hier ist die
sogenannte lobby ich habe auch den
besten skins irgendwie gibt's bei
fordert geht es darum dass 100 leute aus
einem fliegenden bus raus springen auf
eine map diesem app wird immer kleiner
und man wird dadurch gezwungen sich zu
bekämpfen und wer am ende übrig bleibt
gewinnt und das bin eigentlich immer ich
dieser ort ist die sportinsel also hier
sind jetzt quasi alle leute die nachher
auf die richtige insel drauf liegen
werden und willst du jetzt sind wir auch
schon in dem bus hier drin bevor das
ganze spielern allerdings losgeht mache
ich einen siegestanz was party mein
ritual vor jedem spiel ist habe ich
genau passiert ist allerdings eine sache
die die meisten profis machen und ich
spreche da für die meisten profis dann
springt als letztes aus dem bus raus so
dass man sich einen schönen überblick
über die komplette web verschaffen kann
wir sehen daher wo der stadtrat da wo
sind die ganzen web hieraus wir befinden
uns gerade den neuesten meyer
das ist mein absoluter lieblingsort und
gemacht für alle profis die sonne
spiegelt sich im meer
nun können wir hier mit dem fallschirm
einfach ein bisschen rumfliegen und uns
die ganze mit man noch mal so ein
bisschen genauer anschauen wir sehen
jetzt gefordert das ist bin ich ja
eigentlich als absoluter profi landon
wir natürlich abseits von der mep und
sehen schon hh wir sind direkt an der
zone ich habe zum beispiel ein paar
granaten gefunden mit den granaten da
können wir einfach beispielsweise so
machen und dann hätten wir den rasen
hier getötet
hier fordern wir einen green screen
davor nehme ich mir meine videos auf wir
können uns jetzt immer noch ein wenig
umschauen hier fordern wir
beispielsweise eine eine kamera da
können wir einfach mal mit einer leihe
ich habe keine ressourcen deswegen habe
ich die steine rumliegen
da kann man einfach mal so machen dann
können wir nämlich eine steintreppe
bauen und jetzt sehen wir hier seine
kamera
und das ist der sieges an sven paar
sekunden später
ich warte auf gegner ich habe ja einen
zweiten job gefunden weil ich mir
natürlich auch direkt rein so dass sich
hier komplett 100 leben habe
wir sehen dass sich noch eine kiste ist
aber nur scheiße drin
aber meine lieben freunde natürlich bei
der zweiten runde werde ich ein bisschen
darauf achten dass wir eventuell
enthüllte towers rausspringen was ein
ort ist an dem es ein wenig ab geht und
wo ich dann direkt meine 100 kids auch
kriegen viele fordert spieler sagen euch
zwar immer hey hey ground ist wichtig
dass man irgendwie über dem gegner steht
ich finde lau ground ist wichtig weil
man dadurch erkennt dass dieser spieler
am boden geblieben ist und das ist
wirklich bei mir auch unfassbar wichtig
weil ich wirklich durch meine
profikarriere so kraft ach das ist ein
baum gerade ich bin dadurch dass ich der
beste fordert spieler bin erinnert euch
an das schild was sogar meiner tür hängt
gerade dadurch bin ich bei vielen
anderen spielern und medien halt einfach
verliefen immer mit der ruhe
wo siehst du mich ab das ist auch sehr
wichtig dass uns erst mal eine mauer
aufbauen gegenüber dem gegner 2000 jahre
später so dass hier sollte als maurer
erst mal reichen wir jetzt natürlich ein
bisschen mein schild runter geballert
aber der kann da natürlich an der mauer
erst mal nicht vorbeikommen wir selber
kann ich da
ich bin der so genannte beste rock night
spieler wir sind hier tatsächlich schon
unter den letzten zwölf spielern
angekommen also was heißt tatsächlich
das ist für mich natürlich standard
mittlerweile und das halt mit sage und
schreibe 0 kills freuen und das finde
ich meiner meinung nach zeichnet auch
einfach beste spieler aus in diesem
spiel weil dadurch dass ich wirklich nur
pils hat sieht man dass ich auch
wirklich der beste spieler bin ich hab
natürlich auch einen geruch sind dafür
dass wo er kisten stehen das heißt wir
schauen uns manche vornherein hier ist
natürlich nichts drin aber das brauchen
wir auch nicht denn wir gewinnen das
spiel auch so hier ist eigentlich ein
relativ guter platz da wir perfekten
blick über ganz metro haben wir können
genau soll und was seht ihr
eindeutig habe bereits sein leben
freundin vorbei
a
[Musik]
also das hat nicht funktioniert ruhigen
sie sich gar keine sorgen das nächste
match gewinne ich die bereits eine runde
vorhin gesagt werde ich diesmal nicht
ganz am ende herausspringen so wie es
die richtigen profis machen sondern ich
werde direkt meinen stil hierbei teilte
towers beweisen das heißt wir landen
erst mal auf diesem dach hier vorne
drauf auf mein gott dann gehen wir halt
von unten ins haus rein das ist
natürlich auch für mich über alles
sprechen doch dadurch ist für mich
natürlich auch überhaupt kein problem
wir waren uns einfach den weg hier durch
die fassade durch waren hier eine treppe
ich brauche noch mehr holz jetzt
befinden uns die vorne auch schon direkt
im gebäude drin
ich würde es auch mein gott irgendwo
hier sind gegner da ist vorsicht geboten
meine damen und herren auch ich kann
natürlich einen schlechten start
erwischen und einfach mal keine waffe
kriegen die habe ich jetzt allerdings
hier gefunden über uns ist irgendwo ein
gegner das heißt wir schleichen uns
jetzt mal ganz leise daran
das hat gelegt auch in dieser runde ist
unser ziel selbstverständlich wieder
teilte towers da wir hier wieder unseren
skin unter beweis stellen können die
grafik habe ich übrigens extra so
schlecht eingestellt damit ich damit ich
weiß nicht wie man die umstellt gerade
tötet haus ist meiner meinung nach sehr
wichtig dass man weiß wo jede tür hin
führt also das heißt warum einen gott
nein ich jetzt sage ich nicht hin oh
mein gott hat das von mir von fern ich
denke ihr habt alle dieser reportage
heute eingeschaltet damit ihr seht das
ist mal ein bisschen herum hängt und
warum bin ich hier jetzt gesprungen es
soll natürlich ein wenig action geben
von daher würde ich sagen wir hauen uns
mal direkt den ersten
hier der blick hacker ein ganz sensibles
thema aber ich würde sagen noch eine
letzte runde geht hier auf jeden fall da
hole ich jetzt halt einfach mal eben den
sieg wir haben natürlich wieder ein paar
kisten gefunden freuen wir haben direkt
einen dran launcher wir haben hier schon
einige korrekte sachen wir können uns
hier noch ein wenig munition mitnehmen
oh mein gott ich kann fliegen jetzt
gehts hier ab freunde jetzt zeige ich
euch mal vor teilt richtig spielt im
springen wir hier vorne auf das oma
wir können ja fliegen wenn paar sekunden
später
ich sag euch das lag an dieser
beschissenen brille
ich bin wie ihr alle wisst der beste
fordert spieler auch wenn dieser spaß
die ja immer irgendwas anderes behauptet
deswegen spielen wir hier jetzt doch
noch eine allerletzte runde in der ich
euch allen unter beweis stellen kann
dass ich wirklich der allerbeste fordert
spieler bin wie ihr wahrscheinlich schon
mehr gerade an der aufnahme hier habe
ich ein bisschen was gerade umgestellt
an den einstellungen weil es hat schon
ein wenig geruckelt und ich habe ja
sonst mal mit fraps aufgenommen jetzt
nehme ich allerdings mal alles mit obs
auf also ich glaube das läuft schon
deutlich flüssiger oder es aber auch
egal ich meine ich werde es so oder so
gewinnen das verteilte towers ich fliege
allerdings nach dahinten friedhelm welt
hätte towers sind die ganzen ups immer
hier unten haben wir direkt eine kiste
das weiß ich natürlich mit meinem beruf
sind habe ich hab vorhin schon gesagt
wir haben ja auch tatsächlich relativ
heftige sachen drin sogar ein song
satellite den ball ich mir jetzt erstmal
schön minigun freunde
damit können wir auf jeden fall einiges
reißen da hinten ist sogar auch noch
eine kiste ich glaube tatsächlich dass
ich der einzige bin der in vitro
gelandet ist da jetzt noch so ein haft
granatwerfer unseren raketenwerfer hier
in der kasse gehabt
also ich weiß nicht warum hier keiner
hingegangen ist ehrlich gesagt hier oben
ist noch eine kiste das höre ich doch
schon jetzt mal ganz im ernst dafür dass
ich der beste spieler bin habe ich echt
heftiges equipment gerade also ich habe
eine lila niska ich habe eine blaue
taktische ich habe eine minigun einen
raketenwerfer ja okay dafür dass sie
recht relativ gutes luca muss man
allerdings sagen dass ich noch hart
weiter wo mein gott die kommt ja schon
ich konnte hier jetzt in vitro gar nicht
mal so viel
ich war ein präsent parkbox konnte das
leider nicht alles leer luton da wären
wahrscheinlich noch heftig viele andere
sachen gewesen vielleicht sogar ein jump
hätte dass ich irgendwie die zone hätte
springen können allerdings nachher ich
muss auch langsam ein bisschen laufen
haben wir ein gegner freunde das heißt
weil er erst mal schöne granate eine
rakete hin das heißt nach vorne auch
noch schöne rakete hin und rauer mein
gott die zone kommt wo mein gott ich bin
hier gerade einem heftigen gefecht meine
damen und herren aber ich werde
natürlich wieder meines gilt sie unter
beweis stellen ihr seht schon wie kratze
ich hier gerade bauer wo haben wir die
person wir haben natürlich einen blauen
braut ist besser jeder weiß ist da unten
ich bin raus dann per wenig meine damen
und herren ja und meine damen und herren
das war's dann jetzt hier wohl
wahrscheinlich von unserer reportage
über den schlechten besten vor ort ein
spieler wenn ihnen diese reportage
gefallen hat und der luca eventuell
nochmal fordert in zukunft spielen soll
dass ich noch mal gern noch einen leid
dabei 50.000 was junges fakt vorab
dieser bat hier ich bin wirklich nicht
so gut in fordert freunde dann müsste
ich ja nicht diese brille aufsetzen ja
eigentlich bin ich tatsächlich gar
nichts gut